this episode is made possible by the
realistic online game war thunder check
out this game through the link in the
description below go through our link
and not only do support this show be get
a free premium tank or aircraft or ship
and three days of premium time as a
bonus and let's get into it
[Music]
picture the scene it's January the 24th
41 ad and Rome is in chaos the tyrant
Emperor Caligula has just been stabbed
to death outside the Palatine Games in
the city his wife has been murdered and
his baby daughter has had a head - Tobin
against a wall in this tense bloody
atmosphere no one knows what will happen
next will the Republic be restored or
will a new emperor be found who will
take the throne at the height of this
uncertainty a soldier in the Praetorian
Guard sweeps aside a palace curtain and
finds Caligula's useless uncle cowering
in fright but the guard doesn't kill the
old man
instead they proclaimed the uncle
emperor claudius born into the Imperial
Household in the days of August as'
Claudius was a sick feeble child never
destined to amount to much yet through a
quirk of fate he became the only
candidate able to take the throne
following Caligula's murder hounded by
assassination attempts surrounded by
people conspiring against him glorious
nonetheless became one of the greatest
rulers in Roman history join us today as
we plunge into the unlikely story of
Rome's accidental emperor on August the
1st 10 BC the Roman town of lug denim
now Leone in France prepared to welcome
the latest member of the Imperial
Household into the world from the moment
of his birth
Claudius sought to give him his full
name Tiberius Claudius Nero Germanicus
was one of the best connected people in
the whole of Rome his father was the
powerful general Nero Claudius Drusus
while his mother was Antonia the younger
if that doesn't sound so impressive wait
until you hear the next part his
grandmother on his father's side was the
wife of the current Emperor Augustus
so on his mother's side he was descended
from Mark Antony not only that but his
uncle was the future emperor Tiberius
his older brother was Germanicus the
future father of Caligula Claudius
wasn't just born with a silver spoon in
his mouth he was born
practically suckling a whole cutlery set
unfortunately he was also born with a
mysterious disability we say
unfortunately because ancient Rome was
not somewhere that viewed the disabled
kindly the Roman ideal was to be a
strong male who excelled at both
athletic feats and oratory being able to
do only one of those things was
acceptable but neither well boy you are
going to be in for a bad time and a bad
time is exactly what young Claudius had
he limped he stammered his head twitched
oddly and he was known to dribble for a
family that prided itself on being the
most perfectly Roman of all Romans this
was beyond embarrassing talia's his
mother called him a monster of a man not
finished but merely begun by dame naicha
his grandmother refused to speak with
him it said that when poor Claudius came
to dinner the rest of the family would
throw food him and gia mocking him for
his disability if that sounds horrific
just know the Claudius was actually one
of the lucky ones in those days it was
not uncommon for Romans to simply kill
disabled children the only reason the
imperial family didn't do so is because
that would have been an even bigger
embarrassment but while Claudius was
disabled he was by no means the idiot
that his parents thought he was the boy
was insightful intelligent a born
academic at first no one really noticed
after Claudius his father died in nine B
C he was dumped with a tutor who tried
to beat his disability out of him but
eventually more Gustus noticed
Claudius's love of reading and in 7 ad
tried to hire the historian Livy as his
new tutor this was an excellent move
Livy didn't try to beat Claudius until
his disability went away he gave him the
stacks of books to read encouraged him
to write even helped him prepare and
deliver speeches as young Claudius
started to come out of his shell he
began earning the grudging respect from
his relatives no mean feat when you
remember that all of those relatives
were total [ __ ] yes even now the
imperial family kept Claudius from
holding any public office in private
they
agreed he should never ever be allowed
to become emperor
you can always to Majan the fates
looking down on these pompous mortals
and just struggling not to laugh
[Music]
the tortured chain of events that would
eventually lead to Claudius becoming
Emperor began on the 19th of August 14
ad land a august's passed away after
four decades on the throne in the wake
of the first citizens death Claudius as
uncle Tiberius became Emperor now
Tiberius was a weird choice he was about
as popular as they rectally inserted
cactus and he had only been adopted by
August's because he had no other heirs
perhaps realizing the tempura bar cactus
would be a disaster Augustus had tried
to mitigate things by making Tiberius in
turn adopt Claudius's dashing older
brother Germanicus that way no matter
how painful Tiberius was for Rome's
metaphorical backside the soothing
hemorrhoid cream of Germanicus would
never be far behind
unfortunately Tiberius was a guy who
believed in all pain and no gain in 1980
time areas had Germanicus assassinated
in the aftermath he had all of
Germanicus as relatives either killed or
imprisoned we say oh but there were two
conspicuous relatives this sentient
spiky suppository forgot all about the
first was Claudius who Tiberius
considered too weak and useless to even
bother killing the second was Germanicus
a son a preteen boy who went by the
nickname Caligula that was basically how
the rest of Tiberius as rain went
through the twenties ad the Emperor
conducted Byrd shaft purge each time he
spared both useless Claudius and
hopeless Caligula that's not to say
Tiberius liked - stammering nephew he
kept glorious alive because he didn't
see him as a threat but he also made
sure to keep them miserable when the
Senate tried to let the poor guy join
Tiberius personally vetoed it for the
good of the Empire on the other hands
the Emperor also made a choice that was
very much not good for the Empire in 32
AD Tiberius was reaching the end of his
life and he needed an heir his
sundresses had died the decade before
and he needed someone to fill the little
boys boots he chose Caligula technically
this made Caligula his co-heir alongside
Caligula's cousin but you don't need to
bother learning a number two's name
because Caligula quickly made sure there
was no
secondaire to worry about that taken
care of he then smothered Tiberius with
a pillow in 37 ad at least according to
tradition and had himself declared Sol
Emperor since you've doubtless already
seen our Caligula video and if not do we
have a glorious room and click all lined
up for you and you already know that
Caligula's reign was extremely not fun
for everyone in Rome but not for
audience almost as soon as Caligula took
the throne he had his uncle elevated
console the first position of power the
now 47 year old had ever held to this
day nobody really knows why Caligula
showed Claudius such favor
there is range from that he wanted to
keep his potential enemies close to just
well dude it's Caligula he's totally
cuckoo yet even now a dark cloud was
forming that threatened to block
Claudius's unexpected ray of sunshine in
December that year Caligula's sister
Agrippina the younger gave birth to a
son she calls him Lucius Domitius
Ahenobarbus but you know him by a
different name
and that's Nero
[Music]
while Caligula had taken a shine to
Claudius that didn't mean the older man
was safe from his nephews whims by all
accounts Caligula treated Claudius more
like a court jester than a relative
pushing him in the river for fun and
forcing the poor guy to rack up huge
debts funding Caligula's lifestyle still
considering what happens to most people
in Caligula sorbets glorious got off
relatively lightly this was the Emperor
who forced parents to watch their
children being tortured to death the
Emperor who banished his own sister
Claudius as nice Agrippina the younger
to a remote island where she had to
catch sponges for a living by the way
Agrippa of the younger remember that
name anyway Claudius is live under
Caligula continued to be a weird mix of
awful and kind of out K in 38 AD he
married Valerio Messalina an influential
member of the courts ends in 39 ad the
couple had a daughter Claudia Octavia
yet this wasn't exactly true love
Messalina married Claudius because he
was a ticket into the imperial household
the moment they had tied the knot she
began systematically committing adultery
with everything with a pulse the fact
that he was being cuckolded on an almost
hourly basis only added to Rome's
general impression that Claudius was
comically useless but it was this
comical uselessness that made Caligula
treat his uncle more like a pet than a
rival and it wouldn't be long before the
poor abused dog bit back at its master
by 4180 the knives were out for the Mad
Emperor in this case literally on
January the 24th Caligula was stabbed to
death outside the Palatine Games in the
city his wife and daughter were
assassinated in their home but the
conspirators had been so focused on
killing Caligula that they hadn't
planned for what came next the result
was that Rome slid into near Anarchy
that day in the Senate emergency debates
were even held on restoring the Republic
for the Praetorian Guard this was
worrying the private guard of the
Imperial Household they effectively got
all their power from the system of
Emperor's revert back to a republic and
they were done for what they needed was
a new emperor someone who could take
Caligula's place on the throne
ideally a relative ideally someone a
weak someone who could be manipulated
they found their candidate in the most
unlikely place at the moment the
bloodshed erupted Claudius had been in
the Imperial Palace fearing he might be
next it
hidden behind a curtain and there he was
still cowering when a Praetorian guards
Minh yanked it back looking for all the
world like he was going to stab the old
man but there was no bloodshed that day
no murder of Caligula's uncle instead
Claudius watched in dumbfounded silence
as they praetorian guard knelt and
hailed him as their new emperor now
powerful as they were the Praetorian
Guard couldn't just unilaterally declare
Claudius Emperor if the Senate really
wanted to restore the Republic there
would have been very little all these
guys now kneeling around a curtain could
have done about it but the Senate was
too divided so when the Praetorian Guard
presented their candidates there was no
United force to stop them the day they
declared Claudius Emperor you could
almost hear the city grown really
hideous but Claudius wasn't an idiot
these grumbling Romans didn't know it
yet but doddering Claudius was going to
become the greatest Emperor since
August's and just before we get into how
that happens let me take a moment to
tell you about today's sponsor war
thunder who make videos like this one
possible
warthunder is a realistic free-to-play
military vehicle combat game it's
available on PC ps4 and Xbox one is also
no need to purchase this game is
entirely free you just download it and
you play in this game there are over
1200 historically accurate vehicles from
all the way back in 1920 up until the
1990s they're all very carefully built
incredibly details and when you're
playing the game you could see that the
physics has really been sweated over to
make it just right it's a really really
good game and the sound also pretty
amazing and look you can just jump in
for a quick arcade game which is useful
if you don't have much time or you can
play realistic and go for the more
challenging stuff or if you're hardcore
there's always simulator but I don't
play that because I don't like getting
my ass kicked over and over again so
join us on the battlefield for free
using the link below doing that not only
supports this show that you also get a
free premium tank or aircraft or ship
and three days of premium time as a
bonus just for registering and let's get
back to the video
if y'all have been a Roman citizen in
the early days of Claudius's rule you
probably would have felt like things
were off to a bad start
what if gordias his first act was to
bung the military with a hefty bribes
you stop them rebelling against him but
that still wasn't enough because in 42
AD the governor of Dalmatia decided to
go into rebellion regardless this was
pretty embarrassing for Claudius
especially as some senators sided with
the rebel governor but it wasn't fatal
for him at the last moment the
governor's troops rebelled against him
and the would-be revolutionary was
forced to commit suicide still it's not
like Claudius could crack down on the
dissenters or anything like that in this
period the Senate was calling the shots
they declared that Caligula statues
should be torn down and they mostly were
they blocked Claudius his attempts to
bring Caligula's assassins to justice
allowing only the head conspirator to be
executed and by the way if you're under
encoder Yost went after the guys who did
him a favor by icing Caligula ere was
mostly about precedence everyone had
benefited from Caligula dying but you
couldn't have people thinking that
assassination was a legit way to remove
an emperor I mean this was ancient Rome
it was an ancient right oh wait no Mike
the other big mistake Claudius made in
his early reign was oddly to show mercy
remember Agra fina the younger Caligula
sister Claudius is nice and Nero's
mother who got exile to their remote
random islands well Claudius brought her
back to Rome he pardons an errant e set
her up with a new husband to look after
both her and Nero in the long run this
would prove to be a fatal move by the
end of 42 ad Claudius was so insecure in
his position that it was entirely
possible that would be yet another new
emperor within the year what Claudius
needed was a major victory a military
conquest that would show the world he
was more than just a doddering old man
luckily he had just the place in mind
nearly a century ago the great Julius
Caesar had failed to conquer a
rain-soaked Islands north of Gaul that
island's name was Britannia and Claudius
was going to bring it into the Roman
Empire
there's a lot we don't know about
Claudius as conquest of Britannia in 43
ad our only real source is Casius do who
was born over a hundred years after the
invasion but we do know that there were
two major battles with the Britons
finally leading to the established
of a crossing point on the temps we also
do know that Claudius personally went to
Britannia just in time to lead his
troops to victory and we that won him
made reports back in Rome we know too
that he wasn't the only Emperor involved
in the war the future Emperor Vespasian
was among the commander's in Claudius's
army on his own initiative he conquered
the south west of Britain all the way to
modern-day Exeter
by the end of 43 ad Claudius had done
what even Julius Caesar couldn't it
pacified the south of this rainy Islands
while there would be troubles with the
Britons in the future
Boadicea launched her famous revolts in
60 ad for now Claudius was riding high
back in Rome Claudius was awarded a
triumph for the first time the average
Roman in the street was looking askance
at the Emperor and saying well this
dudes not so bad well buckle up ancient
Romans because for a while at least
things are going to keep getting better
[Music]
today gordias rain is best remembered
for territorial expansion and for the
fact that he wasn't either Caligula or
narrow but there were domestic crimes
too and they went beyond merely building
aqueducts Porteous was the first emperor
since or Gustus to really shake up the
bureaucracy while Tiberius had contented
himself with the odd Persians Caligula
has just done whatever wacky stuff
popped into his mind
Claudius tried to seriously reform the
Empire one of his key achievements was
to introduce goals into the Senate Gaul
had been under Roman rule for the best
part of a century but the Senate was
still reserved for those born on the
Italian peninsula this was all fine and
dandy when you were a small conquering
force of Italian groups but when you
were a vast multinational Empire it was
less than ideal Claudius was the one who
broke the taboo of letting non-italians
into the lawmaking process although it
caused a massive fight at the time it
likely saved the Empire in long run
Claudius also championed the rights of
slaves and ex-slaves bringing in a law
that made it illegal to kill your slave
for no reason to modern ears that might
sound like one of those things that
should really go without saying but
before Claudius there had been nothing
to stop a Roman citizen coming home from
a bad day at the forum and stabbing
their slave to death in tandem with this
decree gaudiest began promoting freedmen
inside his own court he made ex-slaves
head of his correspondence head of a
palace treasury and placed them in other
positions too numerous to count for the
Senate this was just another outrage
these guys were former slaves they were
the lowest of the low and here they were
among the Emperor's closest advisors
perhaps it's no surprise malicious
rumors began to spread that the freedmen
were really the ones who were
controlling Claudius and not the other
way around
not the Claudius was a perfect ruler I
mean even if you agree with all of the
stuff that he was doing he was prone to
issuing odd decrees such as the ruling
he passed that farting in public was
good for you so yes I suppose Emperor
Claudius was technically history's first
proponents of better out than in over
although you'd be hard-pressed as an
ancient Roman to say that Claudius was
doing a bad job oh sure the Senate stank
of Imperial bug ass off the time but
stuff was otherwise miserably better
finances were again on a sound footing
after Caligula's access the G dish
was functioning well with Claudius even
personally hearing cases and granting
clemency where the law demanded unduly
harsh punishments yet despite all these
undoubted improvements the Roman elites
could just not get over the fact that
Claudius was well Claudius he still
limped he's still stammered his wife
still cheated on him and for the
toxically nacho Romans it was all simply
too much in his years in charge Claudius
was forced to put over 300 people to
death for plotting against him pretty
much every week brought some new
assassination plots or planned rebellion
yet glorious dodged them all wandering
obliviously through the drawn daggers
like Buster Keaton in a hurricane as
well Claudius was becoming an expert at
avoiding assassination attempts there
was one that he wouldn't see coming
until it was far too late
[Music]
in 47 ad Agra Pina the youngest wealthy
husband dropped dead in mysterious
circumstances leaving the Emperor's
niece in need of a new man this was
fortunate timing because the Emperor was
about to be in the market for a new wife
okay so remember Claudius his wife
Messalina the one he kept cheating on
him well she was still cheating on him
like she was trying to break some sort
of record which she possibly was it said
Messalina Oren's a famous Roman
prostitute had a competition to see who
could sleep with the most men in a
single day and Messalina won the mess
Elena's plans went further than just
getting her kicks behind Claudius's back
like everyone else she was still
convinced that the Emperor was an idiot
to the extent that she actually married
another man in a lavish ceremony in the
heart of Rome the plan was that she
would kill Claudius and her new husband
would assume the throne instead what of
this incredibly not secret secret
marriage got back to the Emperor who was
like all guys what and then he had
Messalina killed and so it was that
Claudius became single again just as
Agri Pina was looking for a new squeeze
now if you've already seen on niro video
and yes we did do the Emperor's very out
of order you already know that Agra Pina
was a woman desperate to secure herself
against future poverty however the way
she went about all of this sort of a bit
throughout 48 ad Agra Pina set her
sights on seducing her uncle Claudius of
course it takes two to tango and
Claudius was just as creepily open to
the suggestion as Agra Pina was when
they got married on New Year's Day 49 ad
the official reason was to unite the two
branches of the imperial family but
Roman society at large was pretty sure
it was just a convenient excuse for
Claudius to live out his weird incest
fantasies but not everyone saw the
marriage as a PR disaster for the past
decade young Nero had been living with
his mother the two quietly biding their
time in 50 ad Agra Pina convinced
Claudius to officially adopt Nero as his
son
now Nero was technically co-heir
alongside corneas as previous son
Britannicus but that hadn't stopped
Caligula from seizing power alone and it
wouldn't stop Nero either the last act
came in 53 ad when Agri Pina made
Nero married Claudius's daughter Claudia
Octavia from having nothing just a few
years beforehand Agri Pina and Nero had
maneuvered their way into the heart of
power
she was the Emperor's wife he was the
Emperor's adopted son and heir and
married to the Emperor's daughter it
should have been blindingly obvious to
anyone watching but Agri Pina and the
teenage narrow were preparing for a
hostile takeover
but as he had been with Messalina
Claudius was blind to the flaws of his
new wife oblivious to the danger he was
in it's likely he never even realized
what was happening
Agra Peter and Nero they made their move
on October the 13th 54 ad that day
Claudius abruptly died from a sudden
sickness while it's not certain what
happens tradition holds that Agri Pina
bribes a court taster to slip Claudius
poisoned mushrooms whatever the truth
when the Emperor was dead Angra Pina LED
Nero to the praetorian guard and had him
declared sole ruler of Rome and that was
that the reign of Claudius it was over
and the time of Nero was here and what a
time it would be as he grew older Nero
would get crazier and crazier until he
finally well let's just say you should
watch our video on Nero
for the rest of that story as Fortius he
was dare fied after his death worshipped
as a god by his former subjects compared
to the fates of Tiberius Caligula and
Nero this was a bit of a win even nero
revoking Claudius his deification in the
60s ad didn't dance the accidental
Emperor's popularity a few years later
Vespasian would restore Claudius to his
place in the pantheon at the end of all
of that excitement and what should we
make of Porteous well from one angle he
was still a bit of a disaster
don't forget without Claudius marrying
Agri Pina you don't get nero who was
arguably the worst emperor of all but to
look at him from another angle it's a
story of inspiration here was a man born
with a disability into a society that
routinely killed its disabled members
only for him to rise to the very top
once he reached the top he ruled with a
sense of moderation and sanity not seen
since the days of August as' he made
life in the empire fairer he saw his
subjects not just as toys he could break
on a whim but as actual people in the
ends glorious may not have been a truly
great Emperor likes
Rajon but he was a good man he was
decent he was kind he wasn't cruel he
was everything his successor would fail
to be perhaps that fact alone is enough
to justify his place in history so I
really hope you did enjoy that video
please do hit that thumbs up button
below also if you want to support this
show do that by supporting our fantastic
sponsor warthunder link below and as
always see you next time
[Music]
you